[Music]
well
good evening ladies and gentlemen i
can't see you but i hope you can
see me tonight i'm going to talk about
the truth
about free will the truth about free
will
is that within certain limits we are
indeed free
this is a practical reality and yet it
just seemed to some people to be
theoretically impossible
in addressing this contradiction i'm
going to take the arguments to places
where those who defend free will
and those who deny it do not usually go
and for this reason the
argument may occasionally prove quite
difficult and i hope i should be
forgiven
because i believe that the difficulty is
inherent in the subject so fasten your
seat belts and let's go
when i say that free will is a reality
this is something that pretty well
everyone accepts in practice
we acknowledge the difference between
something that happens to me
as when i fall down the stairs and
something that i do
as when i walk down the stairs at the
start of a journey to london
to attend a meeting we praise and blame
others inside and outside the law courts
we own up to actions which we feel we
own
the fundamental difference between it
happened and i did it
lies at the heart of human relations and
indeed of what we expect
of each other so much of the practice
or what about the theory actions are
material events
material events are connected by laws
causes
or indeed law governed causes laws are
by definition unbreakable
so what i do must be as subject to the
laws of nature
as other happenings in the universe and
causes have prior causes
and these have earlier causes and indeed
we can trace this causal ancestry
at least to events that took place
before i was born
i cannot it would seem therefore deflect
the course of events
instead of being the true origin of my
actions i am merely a conduit through
which the material world passes
in accordance with the unbreakable
habits of nature
this is the case for what philosophers
call determinism
so it's looking pretty bleak for those
who believe as i do
that we have free will and that we're in
an important sense the source of our
actions
but there is worse to come firstly we
rely
on the laws of nature for our actions to
have predictable consequences
i expect law-governed causality based on
the reliable habits of the material
world
to deliver the outcomes that i want
if action and reaction were not always
equal as opposite
as dictated by newton's laws we could
not walk to the shops
and then there are recent studies in
neuroscience that have seemed to show
that it's not we but our brains that are
calling the shots when we engage in
bond reactions in the famous experiments
by benjamin libit and later john dylan
hayes
subjects were asked to make a simple
movement of the fingers
or their hands at the time of their own
choosing
they were asked a time when they formed
the intention to make that movement
and the experimenters examined brain
activity using various technologies
and what they found was that the brain
activity associated
with a preparation to make a movement
occurred
before the subject was aware of having
formed the intention
or the urge to move the interpretations
these experiments have been to put it
mildly
over excited they have been thought to
demonstrate that our brains are calling
the shots
we are at our brains bidding it confirms
what many philosophers believe that free
will is a feeling
but it is not a force
our sense of being control in control as
one experimenter has put it
is like that of a child moving a plastic
storing a
constant toy steering wheel next to the
real thing held by its parent
there are many methodological problems
with the studies of libert and dylan
hayes
and i'm very happy to discuss them in
question time but i won't talk about
them now because there's something more
importantly wrong with these studies
as attempts to investigate free will and
as attempts to adjudicate
whether we have free will or not
what's wrong with them can be summarized
very simply they completely misrepresent
the nature of voluntary action we can
see this
by thinking about the subjects
participating in the experiment
the study focuses on the subjects moving
her hand or her finger
a very simple movement but participation
involves much more than that
it requires getting to the laboratory on
time after a complicated journey to the
relevant room
and perhaps setting the alarm the night
before to make sure the appointment is
not missed
and even making other complex
arrangements to ensure the appointment
is honored
additionally it requires that the
subjects could under
should understand the general purpose of
the experiment and the part they are to
play in it
following the instructions and accepting
reassurances
the participation was entirely safe
notwithstanding
all the intimidating equipment and all
the folk in lab coats
none of this is represented in a simple
movement of the hand
that that movement is an expression of
agency or free will
only in safari as it is an element of
the action
of voluntary participating in the
experiment
in other words as part of a much greater
hole
looking at the hand movement in the
context of the experiment
as just a hand movement is rather like
seeing
a much trailed handshake between two
national leaders
as a mere arm movement what the subject
is doing
in other words is not merely moving her
hand but participating in an experiment
the decision is not to move the hand or
to move the hand at a particular time
but to take part in the experiment
something
that has to be sustained over a long
period of time
and hardly corresponds to simple
decision or an urge
and then we need to consider the role of
the experimenters who have been working
in neuroscience for many years
who had acquired the necessary skills to
design and carry out the experiments
and had secured the funding and
collaborative expertise to carry them
out
write them up publish them in the
relevant professional journals
none of this looks like something cooked
up in an isolated brain
calling the shots or even clusters of
causally interacting brains
widening our attention beyond the
subject to the experimental team
reveals even more clearly how the
experiment like most
normal cooperative human activity is not
the product
of a succession of discrete urges or
discrete decisions strung together
this is not how free will works
so we may conclude that experiments
supposing demonstrated that this is our
brains and not ourselves that are
calling the shots
are nothing of the kind but these
experiments are nonetheless informative
because inadvertently they are reminders
of the true nature of action
when i do something intentionally my
intention is not a discrete cause
of what i do my intention is inseparable
from my situation
and from broader aspects of myself and
these cannot be separated
from the body that literally situates me
more broadly i could not do what i do
unless i knew what i was doing
and why this is a long way from law
governed causes
a stone does not have to understand why
it is falling in order to fall
what a human agent does is shaped by an
explicit goal
something that she herself entertains
even if it is an action she does
reluctantly
reluctantly
this is a sense in which as many
philosophers have pointed out
actions do not have causes but reasons
or justifications
and reasons and justifications are not
causes
the most obvious difference between
reasons for example and causes
is that instead of being a causal push
from behind
there is a pull from the from the front
from the future
from a sense of a desired possible state
of affairs which we see
or imagine and which we wish for
this is particularly evident when the
goal is long term such as getting fit
or learning to cope with shyness the
numerous
elements physical elements that are sewn
together in the performance of such an
action
would have zero possibility of coming
together as a result
of the unguided operation of the laws of
nature
take my going to the gym for several
years in the hope of getting fit
it involves car journeys freeing up time
buying and wearing the appropriate kit
making sure my subscription is up to
date and so on
this is an ordering of events unlike
anything seen in nature granted all
these elements
are realized in physical movements but
those physical movements would not have
come together
had they not been requisitioned by a
goal as it were trans illuminating
the whole sustained operation
physical movements happen and happen in
the order they do
only because i know what i'm doing and
why
because they are justified by a goal
that i have
and are requisitioned in order to
achieve that goal
actions that have actions have outcomes
that happen
because and only because someone wanted
them to happen
this is a crucial difference between
mere happenings in nature
and the doings of human beings
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas